what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we're gonna be talking about thoughts on
entrepreneurship hmm okay so
entrepreneurship probably the best thing
you'll ever do in your life
entrepreneurship the creative heroes and
heroines journey through the world
innovating bringing forth utility and
meaning and purpose into the world
through your creation what is in your
essence what is that thing that you can
shine through you and bring to the world
and make into it and provide people with
utility it's a money sustain yourself
sustain your family with it grow a team
with it and be really passionate about
it so entrepreneurship okay one of the
best things you'll ever do but there's a
big hero there's a huge amount of risk
that comes with this so a lot of people
don't typically think about the immense
amount of risk that goes on but I mean
I'm talking about your leaving the
potential to earn 100k 250k a year by
you know working your way up through
this nine-to-five a political and
economic machine and rather than
pursuing that and the stability of that
you're gonna pursue instability you're
gonna pursue creativity and what you do
when you do that you put yourself at the
edge you put yourself in a very risky
situation you have very very little
money in your account every single month
you're just scraping by
you're being very frugal you're not
buying new clothes you're not buying new
furniture you're maybe buying a new
computer or phone because it's important
to your business you're being very
frugal with your money you're not going
out as much for drinking and food but
you're maybe buying some groceries and
eating at home there are all these great
things that you actually get to practice
as you grow as an entrepreneur spending
more time working on your business and
applying the Pareto principle the Preta
distribution to your business only 20%
of your meetings are gonna produce 80%
of the rewards that you reap let me see
that again
20% of your meetings are gonna produce
80% of the rewards that you reap
that you reap that means that then that
means both directionally bidirectionally
you're gonna be providing me with value
I'm gonna be fighting you with value
that's the best way to have an exchange
not just unidirectional hermano
directionally so okay so take this into
account
so the Pareto principle of the predator
distribution apply to the amount of
fruits that you can gets really
important rather than taking these
hundred opportunities that are on your
table for this whole year let's say you
can take a hundred meetings this whole
year eighty of those meetings are only
going to produce you twenty percent of
your results that's usually the stuff
where people are like hey like just come
hang maybe just go and you know get a
beer go and do that one little thing at
this one place and maybe you're gonna be
hanging out with people that aren't even
in your industry maybe you're gonna be
hanging out with people that are not
actually like significantly smarter than
you you've got to be hanging out with
people significantly smarter than you
you got to be maximizing your
introverted time so that you can go and
focus on your to-do list and the
execution of your business you got to be
frugal again it's tough to go out when
you're frugal and stuff spending time
with friends is great but spending time
on growing your business can actually be
even better at times but finding a
really important balance so you don't
burn yourself out it's also crucial
Emily Leigh we just talked to her and go
check out that episode about burnout so
on so entrepreneurship in general is
going to be this incredible experience
this crazy roller coaster of ups and
downs you're gonna be rolling rolling
rolling it's gonna be crazy up when you
meet someone really great they might
become your co-founder you start working
together and all of a sudden you go on
and down when you're like crap one of
our big clients just pulled out now you
don't have money next month right so
that's this period of like ah anxiety
and depression and fear and you're like
should I quit I go back to my job what
should I do and so it's important to
just go a little further if you've ever
seen that graphic of the miner there's a
miner that's been mining a really long
time and then he's like [ __ ] I'm never
gonna get to the Diamonds and then he
turns around and goes back and there's
just this thin piece of dirt left
between the mound where the miner
stopped and where the diamonds were
and a lot of the time that's where
entrepreneurs are you got to take more
shots you got to take more risks Wayne
Gretzky you miss a hundred percent of
the shots in life you don't take so you
got to go and take all of those shots as
an entrepreneur as many of the pareto
distribution the 20% that are going to
produce 80% of the fruits take as many
of those 20% of shots as possible over
and over again and you will succeed over
time you have a much higher likelihood
of succeeding over time of achieving
your goals entrepreneurship is the best
thing you'll ever do providing utility
providing meaning providing value to the
rest of the world and to yourself it's
so important to do that's where so much
of our essence and our fulfillment comes
from
it's from making something into the
world and you know artist is an
entrepreneur - they make some beautiful
art somebody else looks at and says hey
I really like that you know and provides
meaning to me - I want to buy that so
that's an entrepreneur an entrepreneur
can be a freaking truck dealer as well
because they're drug dealers getting
some dope and then they're freaking
distributing it as well and they're
making money that way right now
entrepreneur is somebody that is
distributing digital goods like the
crypto kittens that are currently going
on all over the internet as well digital
goods could you believe that who would
have thunk of digital goods 100 years
ago nobody nobody was think about
digital goods so all these different
ways that you can become an entrepreneur
now you can do crazy interesting things
adding some flavor to water packaging it
going and selling it people love
flavored water going in making some new
health kick making some new technology
so many different things that you can do
don't contribute to the noise contribute
to the signal make things that are
highly entertaining or highly
intellectual highly comedic highly
valuable to the world culturally or
emotionally or something that really
provides that value so entrepreneurship
best thing you'll ever do definitely get
started go and tell to people about
entrepreneurship and the importance of
it in our world so much of our
creativity and our innovation that we
have today this camera that I'm talking
to you through the tripod that it's
sitting on the cables that are going to
the TriCaster
the monitor that you're watching this on
the computer that you're using to watch
it all of that is a matter of people's
genius their entrepreneurial genius and
their design and their engineering and
their emotional connection to that
process and to you using this technology
so tell to people have them tell to
people let's get going with
entrepreneurship love across the world
let's get that thing going let's provide
more people with the opportunity to get
on the information Highway to get into
more entrepreneurship so thanks for
tuning in to this thoughts on
entrepreneurship much love everyone